community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
the findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment has many
leaders within the group that are giving
back to the community and that includes
our community of furry friends take a
look
[Music]
tyler it is great to see you and your
furry little friend who is this this is
hashgogo from uh
yeah from the nevada spca hey buddy
how's it going oh my gosh adorable in
the automotive group you guys are always
giving back to our community but it's
more than just monetary donations that
you guys are doing yeah exactly so we we
like to get our people involved we do a
lot of volunteer events and so forth
with a lot of non-profits in town we
also try to get our people on boards and
serve and really make a meaningful
impact with some of the charities so
so today we're featuring the nevada spca
hence the kitty cat the kitty cat we're
over at subaru of las vegas and so i'm
going to introduce you in a moment to
jennifer vitale who's our assistant
general manager here at findlay subaru
of las vegas because she serves on the
board of the nevada spca
we can talk a little bit about what they
do awesome i'll follow you and follow
the kitty cat all right let's go oh
so jc this is jennifer i'm going to
introduce you to her and uh here you go
here's hashtago thank you tyler hi
jennifer how are you
i'm good how are you oh my gosh who's
that this is cherry okay so how did you
get involved in the nevada spca well
from subaru las vegas you know we're
just involved in the community one of
the pillars is subaru loves pets and so
naturally the relationship was built
there and anytime i walked into the
facility it just was a lot of joy and
happiness and i love pets i love animals
so it was a natural fit for me what is
so what are your responsibilities over
there um i serve on the board so
anything honestly that i can help with
um is really what i'm there for whatever
they have needs with whether it's
helping set up with their
fundraisers or helping introduce
different corporate organizations to
them for support just anything and
everything that they need help with i'm
there for and we know that subaru loves
pets we can hear the dogs barking in the
background you actually have a pet area
outside in a pet area inside here we do
we have a dog park outside for all of
the dogs that come on over they can take
a break and just run around in the dog
park out there and then we have pet bowl
we have a pet sink we have snacks for
the dogs so it's endless it certainly is
and you love pets and you love the car
industry you're a leader in the car
industry what advice would you have for
a young and up and cover who wants to
get involved in the automotive industry
yeah i would say you know never give up
on your dreams just keep putting one
foot in front of the other and um
remember to give back you know along the
way remember to give back that's really
important i love it i love it this and
by the way look at hash girl though i
think he's ready to go play in the pet
area ready to go play and go play one we
would take our flights or pets and go
play that sounds great sounds good i'll
follow you all right
come on buddy let's go
such a cute cat if you're interested in
adopting a pet head over to
nevadaspca.org or call them at 702-873
las vegas now we will be right back